I know what you're thinking actually
you're probably not thinking it I am I'm
projecting unto you that which I'm
thinking but if you'll permit me here's
what I'm thinking is this a video on
better call Saul season 5 or the show up
through season 5 I don't know but I find
myself in what I call a an alternate
universe where movies don't come out
anymore and I have to think of things to
talk about and make videos on so I want
to make them about things I want to talk
about better call Saul is one of those
things so if you'll permit me I'm just
gonna ramble about better call Saul tell
you what I like about better call Saul
so better call Saul is essentially the
prequel to Breaking Bad it follows Saul
Goodman who's not Saul Goodman initially
he's Jimmy McGill James McGill is his
real name he's a hustler he's a swindler
he's a lawyer and by the end of this
he's going to be a bigger hustler
swindler and lawyer point is I feel like
calling better call Saul at Breaking Bad
prequel is severely undercutting it as
its own drama because it does stand on
its own two legs as its own drama
don't be honest with you I'm just being
completely transparent first couple
seasons it took me a bit for the show to
hook me it just did maybe it's because
my brain was doing that thing that it
shouldn't do is probably one of the
things that better call Saul has working
against it and that is people and their
brains are gonna go well I'm gonna
compare this to Breaking Bad cuz you
know the universe it's in then season 3
focused up and then season four more so
and now we're into season five and I am
invested which is a very interesting way
for me to say the show just gets better
and better as it goes on like a good
show should I got to say in terms of the
characters this show has compelling
characters it's well cast it's well
acted Bob Odenkirk as Saul Goodman /
James McGill I loved him in Breaking Bad
so I just I loved him at the same
capacity here but you really do see his
side of it you know he's he puts on the
Saul Goodman face when he's hustling but
this is the first time you actually see
his home life I find that interesting
because I'm Breaking Bad any time you
saw him he was in the office working and
Walter White would bust in with a
problem and solve try to fix it give him
a burner phone tell him to call a number
point is we never saw his personal life
now you see his personal life which gets
you more invested which I totally
recognize and understand that was what
the first couple seasons were supposed
to do and they did effectively and you
see that with a character named Kim
Wexler which is really this person who
cares a lot about him and he cares about
her
their relationship I feel like she's the
real tragedy of the show cuz she has the
capacity to make James McGill a better
person however his gravitational pull is
just a bit stronger so he has the
capacity to make her a worse person he
has the capacity to compromise her moral
compass more than she has the capacity
to make him better you know what I mean
you know what I'm saying so really she's
the tragedy of the show just watching it
you know for a fact if he never met her
then he'd probably still be Saul Goodman
doing Saul Goodman things wrapped up in
the cartel he would still be doing his
thing but if she never met him she would
have her little law office her pro bono
work and she would be helping youth out
for free cuz that's who she is and she
still tries to do that but he just keeps
pulling her back in it's shitty for her
I also find it fascinating she's not in
Breaking Bad so the whole time like you
know saw where Saul Goodman ends up but
she's not in Breaking Bad so you're like
where does she end up does she leave him
does she die also like I said you never
see saul goodman's personal life so in
the events of Breaking Bad she could
still be around we would just never know
although that really fascinates me but
from the get-go from the beginning I was
enamored with one of the characters in
here not Joe Varga played by Michael
mando or Michael mando I don't know
which one I'm [ __ ] with names you know
that point is he's like stringer Bell
from The Wire but for better call Saul
he's the business mind he's a very smart
person he's not an evil person
I mean stringer Bell did worse [ __ ] in
the wire than this dude has done in
better call Saul but I still like the
business mind that both had but even
from season one I was like he's my
favorite character in the show but then
Lalo Salamanca Tony Dalton comes in I
believe it was season four he's amazing
he's the kind of villain I just like I
mean he's a true Salamanca he'll kill
you and your family but what makes him
different is the fact that if he was at
your barbecue he would just be hanging
out with everyone everyone would love
him he would be the life of the party
not that he's loud he's just very
charismatic he's very charismatic he's
relatable he's likable you want to have
a drink with this dude that that's what
makes him different than Gus fring like
Gus fring I would probably not hang out
with I mean I'd hang out with if we were
at some five-star restaurant
and you know and he'd have his napkin
and he'd be dabbing his you know like
Gus fring is you can't just hang out
with Gus fring you have to make an
appointment this dude would come to your
barbecue and he'd be amazing and he'd be
awesome and everyone would love him
however if he felt like you were gonna
backstab him you and everyone who loved
him at that barbecue you'd all die don't
cross him he's just he's an electrifying
magnetic personality who's also a
ruthless son of a [ __ ] he's the kind of
villains I love and he's a complete
scene stealer I love this dude and it's
kind of crazy for me to say like oh yeah
you know Breaking Bad loved the show
what the greatest drama on television
ever in my opinion and one of the best
characters ever in that universe is in
the spin-off show better call Saul which
is one of the reasons I say calling
better call Saul a spin-off show or a
sequel to Breaking Bad is severely
undercutting it because it's not just
that it's a compelling drama in its own
right that is to say you see crossover
you see characters from Breaking Bad
like Tito Salamanca he's not in the
wheelchair yet when the show stars how
does he get there I'm almost like that
with tio Salamanca or Gus fring it could
just be like all right we need that
person in here because they were a hit
in Breaking Bad and we need them here
but all of it does serve the greater
story lines they're telling because the
more Saul Goodman or Mike Ehrmantraut
get wrapped up in the worlds of Gus
fring or the cartel them are you gonna
see characters that orbit that world
logistically it makes sense to be weird
not to see those character what could
have just been fanservice thrown in here
for the sake of fanservice stands as
good storytelling elements for better
call Saul it's a true testament of a
prequel standing as its own drama as its
own story and and I really mean this it
expands on some of the story elements
from Breaking Bad like there's a lot
that happens between Gus and the cartel
you know and Breaking Bad there was
tension there and that tension doesn't
just come from the fact that the cartel
killed someone close to Gus fring
decades years ago you know it's not just
that you walk away from better call Saul
with a better understanding of why
things went down the way they did in
Breaking Bad but again it doesn't ever
feel like aura fanservice no it's it's
compelling storytelling you do run into
the thing we're like I know what that
reference is because of Breaking Bad but
still the storytelling tension that's
there and that stands on its own also I
like how each season starts at star
out after Breaking Bad and he is indeed
a manager to Cinnabon and actually those
little snippets are kind of how the
seasons go down in general at first I
was like oh that's a neat peek into it
but don't need to see but it's not like
it's tense for me and then by season
five you're like oh my god what's
happening in that world and it's just
this quick thing that it shows but I
want to see I want a whole season
dedicated to that at least a couple
episodes in the end better call Saul's
become one of those dramas that I I look
forward to now yearly it's not like
breaking bad nor should you compare it
to Breaking Bad but it still has that
Breaking Bad flavor it's like the
creative team behind it's that amazing
restaurant that chef in the kitchen you
know you gotta go there you gotta try
that dish they have the best steak ever
and Breaking Bad was that steak and then
you go there and they're like hey we
have the seasonal fish this time of year
and you're like you know what I love the
steak but I will try the fish and you
eat the fish and you're like it's not
what the steak was but it's the same
quality I've come to expect from this
restaurant and that chef back there it's
still great just in its own right that's
better call Saul by the end of it I just
want to watch better call Saul and then
lead up to Breaking Bad and then watch
Breaking Bad is a compelling world of
crime and criminals and showing how
normal people may be they have good
intentions they get wrapped up in that
[ __ ] also Tony Dalton seriously man all
right so better call Saul have you seen
it are you caught up with it what do you
think about it if the first couple
seasons didn't grip you seasons three
four and five if you put it down before
that you should pick it up again anyhow
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]